muy bien ahora vamos con el inciso de
para investigar la afirmación de que la
exposición a la luz anule el ritmo
circadiano genéticamente controlado los
investigadores planean repetir el
experimento con ratones mutantes que
carecen de un gen que controla el ritmo
circadiano haz una predicción acerca del
patrón de actividad observado en los
ratones mutantes bajo condiciones de 12
horas de luz l 12 y 12 horas de
oscuridad de 12 por sus siglas en inglés
y bajo condiciones de oscuridad continua
que apoya la afirmación de que la luz
anula el ritmo circadiano genéticamente
controlado muy bien así que vamos a
describir estos ratones
mutantes y vamos a hacer dos columnas
ratones mutantes bajo condiciones l 12
de 12 y luego bajo condiciones de
oscuridad continua que esperaríamos por
lo que dice haz una predicción acerca
del patrón de actividad observado así
que los ratones mutantes carecen de los
genes que controlan el ritmo circadiano
pero bajo condiciones l 12 de 12 no
necesitan los patrones circadianos
controlados genéticamente ya que
consiguen los patrones de su entorno que
son la luz y la oscuridad este no es un
gen que de alguna manera hace que no
sean sensibles a la luz así que voy a
suponer que bajo condiciones l 12 de 12
tendrán un patrón de actividad similar
al de los ratones no mutantes
la actividad
es igual
a la de los ratones
no mutantes
inactividad
durante el 12
y
actividad
durante de 12
eso es lo que esperaríamos que sucediera
que aún puedan reaccionar a la luz y la
oscuridad de la misma manera que los
ratones no mutantes lo hacen ahora bien
qué ocurre bajo condiciones de oscuridad
continua los ratones no mutantes dijimos
que se desviaron del ciclo de 24 horas
pero todavía tenían un ciclo en el que
estaban inactivos activos inactivos
activos y cada ciclo fue menor a 12
horas pero no muy distintos
quizás 9 10 u 11 horas de actividad
seguido de 9 10 u 11 horas de
inactividad me imagino que para un ratón
mutante que no tiene algunos de estos
genes para el ritmo circadiano estos
ciclos van a ser aleatorios van a ser
mucho más esporádicos
así que actividad
y mucho más
esporádica
periodos
periodos continuos
más cortos
de actividad
e inactividad muy bien estas son mis
predicciones para los ratones mutantes
bajo ambas condiciones ahora vamos a ver
el inciso en la naturaleza los ratones
son presos potenciales para algunas aves
predadoras que cazan durante el día
describe dos características de un
modelo que represente como la relación
depredador presa entre las aves y los
ratones puede haber resultado en la
evolución del patrón de actividad
observado en los ratones bueno si las
aves que hacen durante el día
si las aves
casán durante el día
es más probable que un ratón se ha
casado por un pájaro si está activo
durante el día se ha casado
por un pájaro
si está activo
durante el día
podría decir que esa es una
característica de nuestro modelo que los
ratones tienen más probabilidades de ser
comidos si están activos cuando las aves
están cazando y la segunda
característica es si tienes más
probabilidades de ser comido entonces es
menos probable que puedas reproducirse
si el ratón
tiene más probabilidades
de ser comido
por estar activo
durante el día
entonces
menos probable
que pueda reproducirse
y si estuviera tomando el examen ap
trataría de poner el mayor contexto
posible aquí ya que no estamos muy
seguros de cómo van a calificar esta
pregunta por lo que podrías dar más
contexto por ejemplo que por lo tanto
los ratones que están activos durante la
noche por lo tanto
ratones que están activos
durante la noche tienen que estar
activos en algún momento e inactivos
durante el día serán seleccionados
de manera natural
tienen
menos probabilidades
de ser casados
y
más probabilidades
de reproducirse
y hemos terminado